there's so much uh wisdom  all around us all of the time coming in  the form of nature coming in the form of  the culture coming in the form of people  speaking at a coffee shop if you're open  and if you're paying attention  because of the subtle nature of the  information that we're looking for it's  not getting shouted at us it's the thing  that if you weren't  really quiet and really paying attention  you would likely miss  so we have to quiet ourselves  and that's the pr that's the practice  and and there are some suggestions of  things that you can do to get there for  different people we we each have to find  what works for us and um and try things  and see what works which is its own form  of openness  [Music]